There is a final judge of all startups
like someday
all will be accounted for. Okay, there
is a reckoning for all startups, right?
And that's either you know when you go
public and the market gives you a value.
You may not like it but that is a
reckoning
>> or it's you get acquired and that is
there will be a number there and someone
will come up with that number.
>> All right, this is uh Dalton plus
Michael. This is a throwback episode and
today we're going to be talking about
the ethics of the startup game. Maybe a
topic that doesn't come up enough. What
do you think, Dton?
>> This was a recurring theme in all of our
talks to the YC batches over the year,
which is
>> there's some basic rule of the game and
one cool thing about, you know, Silicon
Valley and the tech industry is you can
fail and you will be held up and
celebrated by the community, right? Like
it's okay if your startup doesn't
succeed. It's not unethical to fail.
>> Yeah, that's part of the business. You
earn respect from your peers. But we
would always say in our advice to YC
companies, there are rules and if you,
you know, cheat people or lie or follow
bad business practices, you will be in
trouble. You know, like you are out of
the business basically. Like it is it is
very hard if not impossible to recover
from that. And that is not the way to
fail.
>> Over the years, it's be it's become
painfully obvious that we're in a
trustbased business. And I think the
major mistake that founders make is they
overfetishize the next milestone. I
almost want to kill this analogy that's
been popular, which is like, oh, a
startup, you know, first you're pushing
the rock uphill and then it's like
you're pushing it down, you're following
it downhill, and that's the easy part. I
think there's kind of a bit of a
mentality that like do whatever you can
to get to the easy part because then
it's going to be easy and then like
whatever you'll fix it later where like
when we talk to our friends who are
running massive successful companies I
think they haven't found the easy part
yet
like I'd argue it's like it's maybe a
better analogy is pushing a rock uphill
but your legs are getting stronger when
you believe this myth that like oh if I
just raise that around then everything
will break open or if I just hit this
ARR then everything will break open.
>> Yeah. It's like how small lies become
big lies.
>> Like you start by
>> little things and then to keep up
>> you just dig deeper and deeper and
deeper um till you can't recover. Right.
>> Yes. And I think that's the tricky thing
is that you know we're both founders. I
remember there was a moment where you
know I was like we're I'm pitching an
investor and
I'm giving them our metrics right like
like there's no like third party audit
on how many unique visitors we have like
but then you know my next thought was
this is that ultimately I'm being graded
on how much value I'm creating like
ultimately there's an accounting when
that ultimate accounting happens if it
shows up that like Oh, this is all smoke
and mirrors. There's no reward at the
end of that tunnel. Like, you know, so
it's like
>> it's it's all downside, right?
>> It's all downside. But it's weird
because like yeah, maybe maybe it's fun
on that road, but if the end of the road
is like no payoff is the road like is
that what like does it matter?
>> It's not just no payoff. It's like
career end
>> negative payoff. Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. I
think if you look at the history of the
tech industry, um there's like a culture
thing to talk about. I think that
historically
engineering, not software, let's talk
about engineering. The deal with
engineering is you had to build things
that wouldn't kill people like bridges
and buildings and stuff. And so I think
it was built heavily into an engineering
mindset that like details matter and not
hurting people matters and that's
literally the job. Like
>> that's the final accounting. Someone's
gonna walk on this bridge.
>> Yeah. Um and I think it's like pretty
well ground into you. I think the other
thing going on is, you know, not to make
generalizations, but um spectrumy type
people tend to like rules. Um I guess
I'm one of those people. But if you
believe in logic and reason and the
whole way you see the world is through
an engineering mindset of like strict
rules and like everyone has to follow
the rules and like rules are important.
Historically engineering is like a good
place for those types of people
>> because you can put numbers on
everything and you can make sense of the
world and there's laws of physics and
you know there's all these rules where
the where everything makes sense in a
way that other parts of of society may
be a little bit trickier. You still with
me?
>> I agree. The technology industry was
seen as a place for people that feel
that way and think that way and are
aligned uh with everyone agreeing to a
code of conduct and agreeing to rules
and numbers being super factual uh in
every way.
>> Yes. And so I think there's always been
this tension as money flows into the
tech industry that the more money and
lucrative this stuff gets, the more it
attracts people that would not be in
this industry if there were no money in
it, right? Because there's some people
that are like engineers, whether
physical engineers or software
engineers,
>> they would be doing this even if this
was like making no money, right?
>> Because they like it.
>> And there's some people that are 100%
only doing this versus whatever because
>> Right. Yeah, in the 60s it was starting
a rock band, right? Like there's a lot
of people if you're an ambitious young
person in the 60s you started like a
rock band and a lot of people went far
with that. Starting a startup is like
something you do if you're an ambitious
young person. And so where I'm going
with this is that in this cultural
tension, I think a lot of the true nerds
are very angry and upset when they see
what they feel is an injustice. And
again, I guess I'm one of them. Like it
bugs me too. like I, you know, I'm going
to level with you. Um, and that folks
with a different perspective might just
be like, "Oh, this is how everything
works." And it reminds me a little bit
of,
>> I don't know, like high school where
there there are some people that were
like, "Yeah, cheating's just part of the
game." Like, of course we cheat. Like,
everyone cheats. And I don't know, man.
Like, I've always just found it kind of
a drag to to see some of that influence
coming into the tech industry. And like
last thing for me on this point, I've
noticed it it has everything to do with
market cycles and when you know
>> Yep.
>> the hotter things get in terms of money,
the sketchier things get and when
there's no heat on the on the tech
industry, this is less of a problem.
>> I think that investors also have a role
here. It's so funny. I remember reading
something where some young investor
would be given a lot of praise and you
know some snarky Twitter person was like
well those companies haven't even exited
yet and then the reply was like well how
do we grade people if it takes really
really long time I feel like investors
can get caught up in these shortterm
competitions
did I get the hottest company on demo
day like how many of my companies are
raised a series A how fast do they raise
a series A how fast is my fastest
company growing from 1 million to 10
million in ARR because the longer
competitions take so long and I think
that unfortunately when early stage
investors get into this mindset it can
it can help infect the community with
the mindset that these short-term things
matter
and I don't know about you Dolphin but
like man I've been advising startups for
so long now you know time separates
everything out
>> and like the fads go away,
things that don't create value go away,
valuations become irrelevant, the amount
of money you raised, how famous you are.
Like all those things with time, the
only thing that's like the core and rock
is how much value you're creating.
And like sometimes I kind of wish
investors would have that longer term
mindset as opposed to
>> wanting to split the long game up into
short games that probably don't matter
or not indicative of the long game at
all. Sort of to their defense. They're
just worried about their career and
their next promotion and whether
they're, you know, like what we're
saying works for us, but if you're like
a junior VC and your entire career is
based on if you're funding winners,
otherwise you're out. From the investor
perspective, um it's hard for us to to
say they should do bad things their for
their career by not hyping up the
companies they invested in, right?
They're they're just trying to show that
they're good investors and they're
trying to, you know, make their
portfolio companies look good. And so I
understand the incentives are a little
tricky there, but to reiterate what
you've been saying,
>> there is a final judge of all startups.
Like someday
all will be accounted for. Okay. There
is a reckoning for all startups right
and that's either you know when you go
public and the market gives you a value
you may not like it but that is a
reckoning
>> or it's you get acquired and that is
there will be a number there and someone
will come up with that number
>> and so
>> at the end of the day um all the numbers
between when you start and when you end
are a little bit made up
>> and so you should be worrying about your
reckoning value which is how you
articulate the value you're creating
which is a real thing
>> and not
>> fake vanity stuff, you know, like that
stuff's not real.
>> I agree. I I don't want to be on a high
horse here. It is hard and during a
heavy boss game, it's hard. My parting
piece of advice is the advice I often
give to founders when it's like when
they see something blowing up, it's so
often I'll be in office hours and I'm
like, "Oh, well these guys, they're
blowing up. Like, should we chase them?"
I'm like, da da d d d d d d d d d d d d
d d d d d d d d d d d d d d d d d d d d
d d d d d d d d I have not seen games
won or lost in 6 months. And so it's
like don't don't kind of like don't use
some short-term excuse to justify
cheating,
bending the thing, like cooking the
books. like don't use that because
you're overreacting to something that is
probably going to change and that
overreaction is
extremely dangerous like like it it
could be career ending. So like don't
overreact
>> and like destroy people's trust in you
over something that's probably not the
end of the world.
>> I worry a lot about peer stuff. So, I
think a lot of why we used to talk about
this in YC and I guess why we're making
this video is that you can say, "Oh,
these guys, you know, they're full of
crap. They're just saying this, but
every, you know, all the founders I know
are exaggerating their numbers and and
lying to investors and a um that sucks
if that if that's what you, you know,
sorry for you. Sorry to hear that. If
you feel like everyone is doing it,
yeah, like that that sucks. You should
get better friends." Um, and then two,
again, I'm I I really mean this. I know
the numbers of a lot of the most
successful YC companies, and they really
did go public, and Michael can attest to
this, too. They're real. These are real
companies.
Whatnot's numbers are real, and Brexit's
numbers are real, and Reddit's numbers
are real. Like, like, this is audited. I
can't stress enough that the truly
successful big late stage companies are
doing something real.
>> It's like cheating on like a practical
test where you're learning a skill, but
then you actually have to go out there
and like, okay, we we think you know how
to build a house now. You cheated on all
the tests for carpentry. We're now
sending you out there to build a house.
Oh, your house doesn't work. It's like,
well, like what did cheating get you in
the end? like um you know if if there's
going to be a final accounting cheating
ain't going to help.
>> I think in this environment for the
founders who are kind of holding the
line you know we want to say we have
your back like yeah create long-term
>> value. You have a place in this industry
we respect you everyone respects you and
your integrity is the most valuable
thing you can have and you should never
you should never compromise on that.
Like that's it. That's the game.
>> Nope. That's the game. Great chat,
Dalton. Cool. All right. Thanks,